les expériences de fusée et se
poursuivre sous la direction du devin
plombier or le professeur charcot qui
était au goût un peu comme on le sait
crier à travers les barreaux qu'il avait
une idée géniale
le chef shadoks le fit sortir et dit
qu'il s'occuperait de la fusée en
étroite collaboration avec le plombier
la concurrence se disait-il les
stimulerait queen we pendant ce temps là
il pourrait retourner ce qu'on cherche
le devin plombier et se servaient
exclusivement dans ses expériences
scientifiques de son robinet magique et
quand la terre était d'un côté lui avec
son robinet il la voyait pas rond et et
il disait que la fusée il fallait donc
bien la faire monter
certes avant d'être il on risquait de
retomber au long et ms avaler quand même
la tête décennies je te connais tu un
télescope tellement usés que quand on
regarder trop loin avec les rayons se
cassaient de sorte que lui il brigue à
terre par en bas et il disait que la
fusée il suffisait simplement de le
laisser tomber
certes fort et il y risquait de ne pas
aller exactement là où l'on voulait ou
d'aller là où on ne voulait pas mais on
était sûrs aux mains de ne pas revenir
ou l'ont été et comme justement la fusée
ne voulais pas tout ça prouvait bien que
c'était son plan à lui qui était le bon